- We only have a little time left,
but first I am so happy to announce
our first show baby.
(audience claps)
(screams) Congrats to our writer Christina
and her husband, Danny
on the birth of Martha Millie Namchack.
(audience applauds)
Martha Millie Namchack
welcome to the world.
Buckle up it's gonna be a bumpy ride.
But I promise you're gonna love it.
And we're gonna love you right back.
So hi BFFs!
How ya doing?
Wait we have a little
surprise in our audience.
Phil, how ya doing?
Were you at last night's Emmy's?
- Hi Drew, yes I was.
- Oh yes! We've got an Emmy hazmat man.
Thank you Phil for
coming here. How was it?
How was it?
- It was incredible.
It was such a fun show.
I was stationed at Hugh
Jackman so that was crazy.
- I just have to say, your outfit,
you are giving it. This
is a tux 2020 style.
I am so in. Thank you for coming.
- Thank you
- We loved you guys last night.
Okay Erin I heard there was
another question from Erin.
Hello Erin?
- Hi yes. I read your autobiography
when I was in high school and
I have a question for you.
Which I absolutely loved it.
How have your life experiences
shaped the mother you are today?
- Oh my god entirely.
First of all my parents
kind of gave me a blueprint
of everything not to do. Checkity check.
Then I really took all
my life experiences,
and instead of speaking
negatively about them
to my children, cause
I don't feel that way.
I love and embrace all of them,
but it has turned me into
a mother who really cares
about the pillars of appropriateness,
and how to be safe and stay
young as long as possible.
So really all of our life
lessons should be lessons to us
and our kids. Not our
weaknesses, but our strengths.
Thank you for asking that question, Erin.
And to everyone at home. Thank
you so much for joining us.